special treatment for celebrity or
justice a husband and wife visiting las
vegas say a former ufc fighter attacked
them and four other people now they're
livid about a recent turn in the case
against him they spoke first with the
eight news now i-team's vanessa murphy
who has this report from the regional
justice center
former ufc fighter chael sonnen is only
facing misdemeanor charges now and at
least two of the people who he's accused
of randomly beating are upset a felony
charge is dropped i'm completely shocked
i'm extremely
disappointed to learn of this news
i think
for me it just takes me back to that to
that day and julie and christopher
stillfluge says shael sonnen attacked
them as they were walking to their hotel
room at the four seasons on december
18th chris was watching me get beaten by
him i was watching him choke my husband
this
is an individual that did this for a
living to beat people into submission
this is video taken moments after
according to this metro report sonnen
told police he took an ambien earlier in
the day and didn't remember what
happened he received five citations for
battery it appears he was not taken to
jail it was incredibly violent it is it
for us or for me anyway it is the most
traumatizing experience i've ever had
the stealth flukes say they were both
diagnosed with concussions and they
provided the eye team with these medical
documents julie says sonnen split her
lip open christopher says he still had
these marks around his neck a few days
later initially the clark county
district attorney charged sonan with
battery by strangulation a felony along
with 10 misdemeanor battery counts but
in this amended complaint filed by
prosecutors here in court wednesday
sonnen now only faces six misdemeanor
battery charges they object to this
reduction of charges they were never
consulted by the da's office attorney
corey kaplan is representing the stealth
lukes who live in california i got a
call and said we're reducing it back
down to misdemeanors and
we're going to file the motion attorney
david figler is representing sonnen who
he says lives out of state commend the
district attorney for taking a look
checking their own work this is the
check and balance system of the criminal
justice system and today it works but
the stealth flukes say the criminal
justice system failed them the take-home
message from this morning was basically
don't go to vegas and get involved with
an incident with a celebrity because the
criminal justice is not there it feels
um just like we're being re-victimized
in the hallway and i'm watching this
monster beat my wife all over again
they've now filed a civil lawsuit
against sonnen he needs some sort of
repercussions for his actions the next
date for sonnen's criminal case is set
for april 27th reporting in downtown las
vegas vanessa murphy live local now